die weltverbesserer mit globetrotter am
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
weltweit sind über 40 jahre globetrotter
punkte
[Musik]
sie sind für menschen dar denen es
weniger gut geht
sie handeln wenn andere noch regen
sie machen die welt zu einem besseren
ort
tiere
sie sind
die weltverbesserer
[Musik]
als fotograf kommt manuel bauer dem
dalai lama dem geistigen oberhaupt
tibets so nahe wie kaum einer
seit jahren unterstützt er exil-tibeter
in indien und nepal ein dorf für zu
seiner größten herausforderung
samson dass wegen der klimaerwärmung
bedroht ist er will es retten das ganze
dorf soll wanovits flüchtete als kind
vor dem bosnien krieg in die schweiz
jetzt hilft sie flüchtlingen aus syrien
irak und afghanistan wo sich andere
abwenden ist sie dafür menschen die
alles verloren haben
[Musik]
melanie holz gang ist ärzte
in äthiopien setzte sich für patienten
ein die einen unfall erlitten haben
hier wo auf eine million menschen ein
chirurg kommt muss sie schwerwiegende
entscheidungen treffen
[Musik]
endlich
egal
eigentlich ist melanie holz gang
oberärztin in uster hier in äthiopien
wird sie schon bald eine station für
unfallopfer leiten
zuvor arbeitete sie einige monate in
einem spital in südafrika von kapstadt
flog melanie holz gang nach äthiopien in
die hauptstadt addis abeba vor ihrem
einsatz genießt melanie holz kam mit
einer kollegin einen tag als touristik
sie war schon immer interessiert an
menschen und fremden lebenswelten
so spricht sie denn auch sieben sprachen
fließend wir waren im selben flugzeug
sie saßen direkt vor mir so ein zufall
ließen sie da dies ja
woher kommen sie am 2 ich bin
schweizerin
ich bin ärztin an arbeite in einem
spital wie so ausgleichend äthiopien
mein früherer chef hat hier ein projekt
für knochen chirurgie jetzt bin ich an
der reihe hier für zwei monate zu
arbeiten
bloß 200 ja aber normalerweise kommt man
später zurück und zieht sie spezialistin
ich bin allgemein chirurgin der mount
and otto bietet einen prächtigen blick
auf äthiopiens hauptstadt addis abeba
was übersetzt neue blume heißt addis
abeba liegt auf 2300 meter
das zentrum ist urban und modern aber in
den außenbezirken regiert die art der
reichtum ist auf eine kleine elite
beschränkt bei einer kaffeepause
erinnert sich melanie an ihre erlebnisse
in kapstadt
absolut da gibt es ganz viele weiße hai
wir hatten einen server angewiesen
worden
auch hier in äthiopien erwartet die
ärztin komplexe fälle der fotograf
manuel bauer ist in nepal angekommen
bereits zum achten mal reiste er ins
ehemalige königreich muss dann wo er ein
ganzes dorf umsiedelt will in thomson
nimmt er ein sammeltaxi
sein ziel ist das dorf samsung die reise
dauert mehrere tage
von zürich aus flog bauer in nepals
hauptstadt kathmandu
dann reiste er weiter nach chanson im
ehemaligen königreich muss dann über
lohmann tag erreicht er das dorf sant
joan auf 4000 metern höhe
[Musik]
manuel bauer ist angespannt seit zehn
monaten war er nicht mehr hier
sein projekt ein dorf umzusiedeln
bereitet ihm kopfzerbrechen
jetzt schaut wieder so einer phase und
ich überhaupt noch nie weiß wie es
weitergeht und die schwierige suche wird
und eine lösung findet
ob sich das hoffentlich alles wieder die
nächste schlecht quasi aufgelöst
eine weitere wegstrecke seiner
mehrtägigen reise nach samsung bewältigt
manuel bauer zu fuß mit dabei ist der
warum sein übersetzer und seine gute
seele ziffern hat management studiert
und will eigentlich eine mode sorry
kindergarten eröffnen aber erst hilft er
mit manuels traum zu verwirklichen
die rettung von samsung du hast
versprochen bis zum schluss dabei zu
sein
nun hat sich wieder alles verzögert das
tut mir leid ich glaube ein paar
gespräche sind ja bald beendet ja hoffen
wir es
ich bin ziemlich nervös mit dem
traditionellen tibetischen groß möge ist
ihr wohlergehen trifft manuel bauer auf
seinen freund und engsten mitarbeiter
den la manga bisher ist heiß schön dich
zu sehen der tibetischer mönch lädt
manuel baur ein seine schule ein
sie wird von der schweizer stiftung
immer layers children getragen
[Musik]
ein großer empfang erwartet ihn über 100
kinder legen ihm eine karte um die gute
wünsche und schutz verheißen
[Musik]
manuel selber vater zweier kinder ist
vom empfang überwältigt
[Musik]
die schule wird durch schweizer spenden
ermöglicht die kinder lernen hier nepali
englisch und vor allem ihre
muttersprache tibetisch
[Musik]
spätabends in zürich wenn jetzt neue
witsch kehrt heim von einem treffen mit
dem verein wurde free association
morgen fliegt sie nach serbien wo sie
flüchtlinge auf der balkanroute hilft
vor monaten zog sie alleine los jetzt
hat sie die unterstützung vieler
freiwilliger die für den verein arbeiten
am nächsten morgen am hauptbahnhof
zürich
wenn ihr sohn moritz trifft ihrer
kollegin sonja bischoff die ebenfalls
für den verein bode free association
arbeitet
wenn sie mich kriegt was das ist bei den
erwartet
geworden
alles klarzumachen
die subvention mir geschenkt dasselbe
gemacht und sind 22 für den schweizer
die situation auf der balkanroute ist
verfahren
wenn jetzt neue patch ist gespannt und
will sich ein eigenes bild der situation
vor ort machen
sie hat selber erlebt wie es ist wenn
man die heimat verlassen muss und setzt
sich nun ihrerseits für die flüchtlinge
ein
[Musik]
wir sind in der äthiopischen stadt
zimmer im universitätsspital wird
melanie holz gang die unfallchirurgische
abteilung übernehmen
ihr vorgänger michael schmelz zeigt ihr
die klinik von der hauptstadt addis
abeba dauert der weg nach thema mit dem
auto zwischen sechs bis zehn stunden je
nach zustand der straßen
guten tag
das ist melanie meine nachfolgerin ich
werde ersetzt
und ich bin der von da drüben
er ist einer der erfahrensten pfleger
hier er ist sehr zuverlässig das ist der
name für lungen ja so heiß ich herzlich
willkommen
danke ja wir teilen uns die arbeit sie
ist klug und ich gut aussehend das
spital mit 60 betten ist stets über
belegt denn es ist die einzige
unfallchirurgie für zehn millionen
menschen
die patienten kommen von weit her auf zu
spät
die fehler sind dementsprechend komplex
er hatte eine infektion
die platte wurde vor fünf monaten
entfernt das weichgewebe ist okay aber
es heilt nicht
ich denke es ist immer noch infiziert
ich würde die wunde öffnen und eine
gewebeprobe entnommen
wenn es eine infektion ist lege einen
zugang und verschließen sie wenn es
keine ist setzte eine kommission platte
ein
das werden wir nächste woche machen für
dich selbst sehen welche fälle kannst du
machen welche fälle mussten medizinisch
strom nicht machen und du musst
zwischendrin einzelne fälle einstreuen
die schnell operiert sind ganz neue
patienten von der notfallstation den
lokalen assistenzärzten folgt die
33-jährige auf die frauen station
die freiheit für panik aber der hand in
hand eingangs kurz bevor ausgediente
zwischen auch wenn du die fahrer gewohnt
beharrlich hätte dass kontakte
entwickelt von der hand wie sich das
jetzt an produktionen vom arm ein
rituelles sie zuerst die schmerzen im
arm was eine künftige forschungen
anderes bayern interessieren die
phantomschmerzen
oft suchen die menschen auf dem land
hilfe beim schamanen die patienten die
den weiten weg ins spital überleben sind
schwer krank
gerade mal zwei tage wird melanie von
michael schmelz eingeführt dann musste
ich die rog in die verantwortung alleine
tragen
manuel bauer leitet an der ehemaligen
königsstadt lohmann vorbei dann gegen
die werbe die sicht auf jenes stück land
frei auf dem er das dorf samsung neu
bauen will
es gibt drei möglichkeiten aus der 10
der helle ebene links vor dem pub wird
das ganze schwarm land das delta eine
art hätte könig st am dorfversammlung
zum detail eine umsiedlung das problem
ist auch dass das sehr gefährdet ich vor
überflutung sicher alles über schwank
sich mit riesige steine will das
blütenbad damit frei ja ihr schafft
großes risiko und dann versucht der
hügel recht vor den bug übertroffen der
talschaft dass öffentliches land und
dass ich bis jetzt nicht glückt und dann
hat man alternative gesucht wird eine
dem fluss privatland stunden später
erreichen die beiden den ort der schutz
gottheit von samsung
wir sind auf 4000 meter höhe über meer
in samsung erwartet manuel bauer und
sein weggefährte ein warmer empfang
die menschen haben hohe erwartungen an
ihn
denn der fotograf soll das dorf das
wegen der klimaerwärmung keine zukunft
mehr hat retten
wanovits ist in mazedonien gelandet und
wird von sami allagui abgeholt sie flog
von zürich nach skopje und fährt nun mit
dem auto nach serbien in die grenzstadt
peshawar
heute abend da warten mehr 760
flüchtlinge auf der einstündigen
autofahrt will man ja alles über die
aktuelle situation wissen jetzt
übernimmt sie die führung
das label gold kann seine stars als
einfach blöd kann ich mit den atom man
redet viel
der weg nach brescia wo ist teil der
berühmt-berüchtigten balkanroute seit
akkus 2015 reist waren ja nach peshawar
wurde free association hat hier ein zelt
und container aufgestellt
sie kennt alle hier mein freund wie
geht's meine liebe wie geht's gut und
ihr mit schlecht seit dem erfrieren
es ist kalt habt ihr eine heizung da
haben wir und wie geht's euch gut auch
bei polizisten hat waren ja keine
berührungsängste
er soll mich nicht filmen mein
allerliebstes nicht drehen er ist
polizist
sie machen einen dokumentarfilm okay
aber uns dürfen sie nicht filmen
ich weiß ich habe es ihnen gesagt
im halbstundentakt treffen busse mit
flüchtlingen ein
die menschen kommen aus syrien
afghanistan und dem irak ihre letzte
station war mazedonien in serbien müssen
sie sich im camp der un hcr erneut
registrieren
erst dann dürfen sie bis an die grenze
zu kroatien reisen im zelt trifft man ja
weitere bekannte ein arzt von mit
software die erzählt gleich nebenan
haben das hilfsprojekt funktioniert nur
dank den volontären die hier zweiwöchige
unbezahlte einsätze leisten
und jetzt sagen sie die grenze zugemacht
und mazedonien automatisch auch zu acht
stunden
viele kommen
[Musik]
neue flüchtlinge kommen an unterkühlt
müde und hungrig
[Musik]
die heiße linsensuppe die turbo kommt
gerade recht zurückstehen bitte wir
haben ja hier 500 menschen stehen an
willst du djerba land wandte wir haben
kein fanta nicht fünf personen
gleichzeitig immer nur einer nacht im
anderen ihr müsst warten
wanja versucht den überblick zu behalten
[Musik]
ein neuer tag in zimmer in der
unfallchirurgie herrscht bereits früh
morgens viel betrieb in die sprechstunde
kommen täglich bis zu 100 patienten
mittendrin chirurgin melanie holz gang
und michael schmelz und dann alles was
du machst entscheidungen braucht
operation braucht auch wieder auf den
ersten zweitens drittens gibt sich
zurück zum nächsten melanie holz kann
muss lernen schneller und harte
entscheidungen zu fällen
sieht nicht gut aus es ist ausgerenkt
wir brauchen noch ein röntgenbild sieht
nicht wahnsinnig schön aus eine solche
missbildung ist bei uns kaum mehr zu
sehen
melanie holzkern muss die mutter aber
auf später vertrösten
die plastischen chirurgen aus luzern
kommen in fünf monaten
abraham soll das kind auf die liste
setzen dann endlich kann die chirurgin
ihre erste operation machen
auf dem operationstisch liegt ein junge
der beim honig ernten vom baum gefallen
ist er hat beide handgelenke gebrochen
nach dem eingriff eine kurze
verschnaufpause
aber das schicksal des jungen
beschäftigt melanie holz gang weiter
das mache ich mit dem armen kerl machen
was fehlt ist eins von vielen mit
offizieren natürlich immer nach dem bund
zustande nachdem verbands zustand aber
am besten jeden zweiten tag auf den plan
reagieren muss mich denken dass du hast
jeden zu behandeln du musst medizinische
innovation ende musste ich behandle ich
du kannst last der zwischentöne in
person
den gebe ich es maximal eine chance
die ärzte müssen schicksal spielen muss
dann bricht ein neuer tag an cassano
ruhm macht morgen wäsche bei der nicht
der dollar die fünfjährige kann den
neuen tag kaum erwarten in seinem zorn
gibt es 1507 ihre pashmina wolle
verkaufen die samsung gas im winkler
sie ist eine wichtige einnahmequelle
manuel bauer will sich heute zusammen
mit der bahn um das dringlichste problem
die wasserversorgung kümmern
[Musik]
das wasser wird hier oben immer knapper
schuld daran ist die klimaerwärmung ist
manuel überzeugt die schneefallgrenze
klettert immer höher und lässt den
natürlichen wasserspeicher schrumpfen
darum hat manuel den bau dieses brunnens
mitfinanziert das grundwasser soll zum
trinken und bewässern dienen
aber dieser plan war ein schlag ins
wasser
das heißt als trinkwasser für die 85
menschen von samsung
aber es war ja auch für die felder
gedacht wenn man 15 minuten lang pumpten
keller leer und dann müssen sie wieder
eine stunde warten wieder 50 minuten
punkten
so reicht das nicht für die felder das
brunnenprojekt ist ein flop und doch
glaubt manuel dass es den versuch wert
war
twitter versucht auch cursor nur um den
feldern etwas essbares abzuringen
[Musik]
hier im entlegensten winkel nepals sind
die menschen selbstversorger und ganz
auf sich gestellt
alles wird verwendet der ziegen mist ist
naturdünger aber ohne wasser
fruchtet alles nichts etwas weiter weg
wird wasser vom fluss abgeleitet aber es
ist salzig und die zufuhr unsicher
das reicht nicht aus
diese kanal ist wegen der fusion
gefährdet wegen des wassers während des
monsuns das ist ein riesiges problem für
die bewohner von samsung
wenn er zerstört wird trocknen die
felder aus andere ist klar vor der
überflutung und erosion und so im und so
viel stärker worden
manuel ist überzeugt dass der westliche
lebensstil dieser menschen am anderen
ende der welt zu klimaflüchtlingen macht
am frühen morgen im serbisch
mazedonischen grenzstädtchen pressure wo
noch ist der bahnhof menschenleer
wieder kommen flüchtlinge an
fast alle wollen nach deutschland und
das so schnell wie möglich
ein neuer ansturm den die freiwilligen
in bordeaux free zelt bewältigen müssen
sie helfen auch mit warmen kleidern aus
samir chalabi der partnerwahl us der
syrisch und serbe spricht hat eine
syrische familie mit fünf kindern
entdeckt drei sind schwerbehindert und
sitzen im rollstuhl
sie brauchen dringend trockene kleider
im nahegelegenen shoppingcenter versucht
das team das richtige zu finden
zurück im camp zurück bei der syrischen
familie für wanja ist es fast
unvorstellbar wie die familie mit den
drei behinderten kindern die flucht
bewältigen konnte
wenn ja wen sie unterstützen kaum ein
wenig geht noch ein moment der
ähnlichkeit der vater ein zimmermann
malt mit seiner dreijährigen tochter
einer er erzählt samuel von der flucht
sie waren zwei jahre im libanon und
eineinhalb jahre in der türkei
dann gingen sie nach und warteten dort
sieben tage schließlich überquerten sie
das meer in fünf stunden von der türkei
der vater hat gehört dass es in
deutschland gute ärzte geben soll
die den kindern helfen könnten aber das
geld ist ausgegangen den schleppern
bezahlten sie für die überfahrt 2000
dollar
viele schicksale kommen hier zusammen
ein mädchen aus afghanistan zeichnet
ihre erinnerungen
das ist ein schulen sie wurde
geschlossen und das ist eine bombe und
vater mutter bruder weinen und das sind
gefährliche taliban im container den der
verein wie auch das zelt mit hilfe von
spendengeldern aufgestellt hat soll sich
die familie zurückziehen können wenn ja
gibt in freiwilligen anweisungen was man
hören dass das setzt die spätphase zu
mitfahrt was man wissen dass sie das
schlafen die anderen immer ein
selbstläufer
der zug zur kroatischen grenze fährt
wenn alles gut läuft zweimal täglich die
menschen warten stundenlang im freien
aus angst keinen platz in zu göttern zu
können
ein mädchen ist in ohnmacht gefallen
seit tagen habe sie nicht mehr richtig
gegessen sagt ihr bruder
training
der arzt von mit software kommt zum
einsatz
in der äthiopischen stadt immer gibt es
für dich robin melanie holz gang alle
hände voll zu tun
noch ist alles neu es blutet und blutet
weit weg von der schweizer
spitzenmedizin ist hier improvisation
gefragt denn es fehlt an allem
blutkonserven verbandszeug latex
handschuhen
noch kann die ärztin auf die erfahrungen
ihres vorgängers michael schmelz zählt
die pausen sind kurz ja ich komme
der patient liegt schon auf dem tisch
ich komme schon mal an
machst du denn fürn ar mit dem hand ich
ja mit am tisch
ich rufe dich dann
haben wir einen hand tisch die
assistenzärzte schauen zur ausbildung
gehört zum programm dann ein
schreckensmoment der strom fällt aus
mitten in der operation
unsere kamera lampe kommt zum einsatz es
hat viele gefällt in herten strukturen
darum mit einem gerade operiert und das
ohne licht ist nicht ganz nett ganz ohne
aber sie ist gott sei dank ja schon
wieder auf dem rückzug
wenn mein passiert natürlich auch am
anfang der aktion passieren können und
dann jetzt natürlich ganz anders
ausgesehen
trotz aller schwierigkeiten ist melanie
holz gang überzeugt am richtigen ort zu
sein
im spital delsberg arbeitet der frühere
chef von melanie holz chirurg york
peltzer ist der gründer des spital
projekts co star im gym
diese patientin hat eine
blinddarmentzündung
was in der schweiz ein routine eingriff
ist ist in äthiopien ein todesurteil
in neun von zehn fällen darum fühlt sich
pelzer dort gebraucht und schlussendlich
kann ich mit boston als chefarzt in
seiner position sage ich 50 prozent
reduktion und behält in afrika und
hälfte war das möglich aber im moment
abgibt und solang muss ist parallel
machen aber viele tolle leute sparen die
leute mithelfen und salzen der blinddarm
eingriff erfolgt invasiv der
operationssaal ist bestens ausgerüstet
in jim ist das ganz anders
durch nicht wenige fort und will in
afrika muss man doch improvisieren
kurz und gut das man immer alles
material hat dass man sich neues
material verleiht das technologie und in
afrika doch meistens besonders
materialien wie holz nämlich braucht wer
bald wird auch jörg peter wieder nach
china reisen
[Musik]
zurück in muster zurück im dorf samson
das von der welt fast vergessen scheint
das nächste spital ist mehrere tage
entfernt
die schule ist meistens geschlossen den
lehrern ist das dorf zu abgelegen der
fotograf manuel bauer besucht mit seinem
übersetzer den dorfältesten phantasie
ist 78-jährige alle nennen ihn nur
mensch er wird von allen als
respektsperson geachtet wenn er sich
zurück erinnert an seine jugend kann er
uns sagen wie viele felder sie seither
aufgeben muss als ich jung war vor 60
jahren
da brauchen wir zwei tage um die felder
zu pflügen heute brauchen wir dafür
etwas mehr als einen halben tag
das heißt wir haben etwa 70 prozent
verloren
was ist eine erklärung dafür dass es
immer weniger wasser gibt der mensch ist
schuld
sie gehen zu nah an die wasserquellen
holzen zu viele bäume und zerstören die
erde
das ärgert die geister in den quellen
und sie lassen sie austrocknen
[Musik]
in der äthiopischen stadt immer heißt es
abschied nehmen
michael schmelz reis zurück nach
deutschland
der chirurg michael schmelz plant noch
einmal nach thema zu kommen rund um
georg sein und arzt sein mit mit allem
was dazugehört du kannst alles verwenden
beispiel bei einer ausbildung gelernt
hast du bekommst vielen dankbarkeit für
die arbeit
[Musik]
gut also guten flug
in der nächsten folge kommt melanie holz
gang unter druck sie trägt die
verantwortung für die ganze
unfallchirurgie auch jörg pelzer ihr
ehemaliger chef kommt nachts immer am
bahnhof von brembo tun war zur neue
witsch und ihr team alles dafür damit
die syrische familie weiter reisen kann
in nepal ist die landfrage ungelöst aber
bereits waren schwere maschinen vor
manuel bauer hat gleich mehrere probleme
[Musik]
die weltverbesserer mit globetrotter am
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wartet seit über 40 jahren
globo.com